je rêve d'une ville qui raconte notre
histoire
et qu'ils imaginent l'avenir le grand
paris se dévoile sous la forme d'un film
quatre minutes pour présenter ce projet
qui ont multiplié les distinctions
le film a reçu en octobre trois prix
lors des festivals cannes corporate et
médine corporate de deauville derrière
ce succès david martin et sa société de
production originaire de plaisir on
espère et on espérait vraiment avoir un
peu de succès quand même un retour très
positif sur ce film parce qu'on s'est
vraiment investi
c'est un vrai défi on a tourné avec des
caméras vraiment de dernière génération
pour faire des traits des images très
ralenti comme on peut voir le saut la
personne qui saute
tu la gare du champ de mars au château
de versailles
vingt jours de tournage dans toute
l'ile-de-france ont été nécessaires
commandé par la société du grand paris
le clip a été diffusé en juillet dans
les ambassades françaises derrière cette
première diffusion
ils sont été en fait sensibiliser les
investisseurs internationaux pour les
pousser à participer à investir dans le
grand paris et dans les quartiers de qui
nous ont tout de suite fait confiance en
fait pour qu'on leur propose plutôt un
film original qui sortent des films
institutionnels qu'on peut voir en
général et qui privilégie justement
l'humain l'émotion pour pour commencer à
sensibiliser les gens en fait c'est
sprott fête cette année ses 10 ans c'est
la première fois qu'un de ses films est
récompensé l'oeuvre continue de faire le
tour des festivals prochaine étape tokyo
verdict le 25 novembre